розпочалась для того щоб ми розуміли в
який момент нам
розпочинати колеги з пресслужби мене
чутно
пишуть що запускають
добре значить
не чутно
Так значить колеги ми розпочинаємо
панельну дискусію яка присвячена
питанням відкритої науки
з нами сьогодні
до нас сьогодні долучилась
ряд експертів ряд представників
Міністерства освіти і науки України
представників наукових установ закладів
вищої освіти і ми в чергову поговоримо
про ті ініціативи які були запропоновані
суспільством які були запропоновані
державними службовцями для реалізації
принципів відкритої науки в Україні
на початку я представлю присутніх на
цьому заході
Мабуть я буду говорити називати вас А ви
вже зможете сказати всі свої регалії які
ви хочете про себе сказати для того щоб
не було якоїсь бояркості в цій історії
розпочну за своїм віконцем з пана
Олександра Олександр березка
представтесь будь ласка Доброго дня усім
Олександр Бориско доцент Львівської
політехніки президент євродок
Європейської ради здобувачів наукового
ступеня та молодих
Пане Андрію ваш Андрій Василенко
державний експерт з питань цифрової
трансформації освіти і науки України в
директора трансформації Міністерства
освіти і науки України
пане Володимире
Володимир камишин директор українського
інституту науково-технічної експертизи
та інформатиці
дякую пані
професор Чернівецького національного
університету імені Юрія Федьковича офіс
підтримки вченого Радимо де вчених про
Міністерстві освіти і науки України
дякую пані Олена
вас не чутно включіть будь ласка
мікрофон
і багато річної учасник проекту
ініціативи партнерства картини
Дякую пане Олексію
Олексій сухий заступник директора у
карантин інформаційних технологій
пане Олексій у вас камера запрацює
Я просто на жаль так вийшло по справах
тому я можу природу навколо показати але
думаю що там негарно що буде можливість
то з часом підключитися будь ласка
Дякуємо якщо до нас ще хтось
приєднається то я потім представлю
значить я Григорій Базилевич представляю
директорат науки та інновацій керівник
експертної групи з питань інтеграції до
Європейського дослідницького простору
з вами обговоримо ті Скажімо так
положення які були запропоновані
громадськостю обговорення
експертами потім зведені міністерством
щодо нової ініціативи програму відкритий
уряд на
2023-24 рік
ці цей документ нам з вами відомий але
він невідомий громадськості Я сподіваюсь
що він найближчий час буде затверджений
уряд серед переліку тих завдань які
мають місце в програмі відкритий уряд
таких завдань десятки будуть для уряду
України ну і з такими завданнями для
урядів інших країн світу можна
ознайомитись на відповідно створеному
порталі цієї ініціативи так само і те
про що ми будемо говорити також буде у
відкритому доступі і відомо всьому світу
значить я трошки нагадаю з того що було
раніше ну по-перше ми у 2021 році
підписали угоду про участь у програмах
горизонт Європа та Європи в рамках цієї
угоди була відповідна стаття яка
під якою підписав ось наша країна і ця
стаття говорить про те що ми будемо
реалізовувати в державній політиці
принципи відкритої
далі у 22-му році в жовтні місяці наш
Уряд прийняв Постанову якої затвердив
затвердив національний план щодо
відкритої Коли наша когорта створювала
проекції постанови відповідно робоча
група була створена тому говорили про те
що термін на виконання тих чи інших
речей розтягнеться десь приблизно до
2030 року цієї ініціативою про яку мова
йде у програмі відкритий уряд будуть
конкретизовані деякі кроки що стосується
виконання цієї програми цього
розпорядження протягом
23-24 років
з попередньої програми відкритий уряд
навик по суті було реалізовано те що
прописано в проекті розпорядження і
прийнятому розпорядженні Тобто було
затверджено національний план щодо
відкритої була ще інша ініціатива яка
знаходиться по суті зараз у стані
виконання це
законопроект яким визначено
деякі зміни до Закону Про наукову
науково-технічну діяльність що
стосується термінів відкрита наука
дослідницькі дані деякі уточнення що
стосуються дослідницького інфраструктури
є інфраструктури тощо Зараз я вам можу
повідомити щоб буквально Вчора ми
отримали погодження цього законопроекту
від Міністерства фінансів України Це
говорить про те що він найближчий час
може потрапити на розгляд уряду Ну і
відповідно урядом вже спрямований на
розгляд Верховної Ради України це досить
такий поту жний великий законопроект
який ми будемо сподіватись потрапить на
розгляд Верховної Ради і буде
підтриманий народними депутатами Таким
чином ми будемо мати законодавче поле
яке визначає
основи
навколо питань відкритої науки це така
була моя вступна мова Ну А далі Давайте
поговоримо ближче і детальніше про
програму відкритий уряд і про завдання
яке називається так забезпечення
прозорості та доступності інформації
щодо наукових досліджень на
2023 24 роки це завдання було розбито на
5 окремих кроків
за потреби я можу В принципі транслювати
свій екран для того щоб ви бачили про що
йде мова якщо у вас цих кроків немає на
жаль в мене поки заборонено трансляція
екрана нашої прес-служби якщо буде
можливість будь ласка дайте мені дозвіл
на цю трансляцію поки розпочну в такому
візуальному тоді режимі
значить завдання номер один зробити
доступною та легко відшукуваною
інформацією про наукові дослідження і
розробки що виконуються Із залученням
коштів державного та місцевого бюджетів
на цьому кроці було завдання
№11 сформульовано забезпечити на
ресурсах у карантині відкритий доступ до
реєстру розпочатих виконуваних
завершених відкритих
вір а також захищених дисертацій колеги
Хто хоче з цього приводу щось сказати
прокоментувати будь ласка
пані Олена
стосується те що стосується даного
пункту
Як ви знаєте
збігає інформацію по всіх
науково-дослідних роботах які
виконувались в Україні з 91-го року От і
також по всіх захищених дисертаціях
знову-таки з 91-го року і зараз всі ці
дані
включаючи звіти і самій дисертації
автоефекти знаходяться у вільному
доступі от хоча
завдання стають до реєстру якщо не
помиляюсь да
більш сіль дані у відкритому доступі за
винятком ще не досканованих диситацій з
91-го по
94-5 рік там паперові майже всі
сканували
ось з тими як і є на мікроафішах є певні
проблеми
пов'язані з
тим що
нема сканер бо мікрофіш
А те що десь з 96-го року відповідно є
вільний доступ до повних текстів
по де є звичайно
Ну в зв'язку з певним неналежним
зберіганням
попереднім керівництвом кнте вот вони
там були в підвалі дикі деяких
дисертації немає Ну це дуже невеличкий
відсоток от порядка одного відсотка Але
у нас є домовленість з національною
бібліотекою Вернадського і ми поступово
ці дисертації скануємо будемо сканувати
і відповідно вони будуть також в базі
даних
Дякую пане Володимире
стосовно дисертації тут Зрозуміло Тому
що всі дисертації надходять до
Національного репозитарію тому пошукових
механізм репозитарію дає можливість
відібрати будь-яку інформацію стосовно
роботи науково-дослідних які виконуються
зараз працює стара онлайн система в якій
є можливість просто отримати будь-яку
картку з наукових робіт А в Новій
системі яка зараз створюється відповідно
до нового порядку державної реєстрації
вже заплановано можливість такого
розширеного пошуку по
науковому роботам як по тим що закрилися
так і по тим що лише почали свою
виконання
Дякую пане Олексію п Андрійко прийшов
інформація щодо того що частина
дисертації матеріалів дисертації
знаходяться на мікрофіш носіях
Я пам'ятаю цю історію Уже ми говоримо не
перший рік і Міністерство щоб не
помилитись років півтора-два назад
довжина надсилали листа доуки стосовно
пропозиції опрацювати можливість
залучення ДТП України до зчитування
такої інформації Наскільки я знаю у них
прилад для зчитування з мікрофішів є
Скажіть будь ласка чи було що зроблено у
цьому напрямі
дійсно в них є сканер з мікрофіш але на
жаль він з мікрофіши скануються там в
ручному режимі ми порахували для того
щоб цей масив з сканувати потрібно
приблизно 18 років потрібно сканер який
автоматично автоматично подає мікрофіший
і автомати чно зчитування
дякую
пані Олена
Я би хотіла додати до того щоб було
сказано дійсно зроблено дуже багато і
повні тексти дисертації і навіть Декарт
а представлені у репозиції
обмеження і люди вже звикли звертатися і
шукати свої дисертацію опонентів і
просто по темі наукові дослідження і це
ця практика У нас вже є серед науковці
якого освітян але на жаль я не можу
представити демонстрацію своїх там 3-4
слайдів
не треба перемикати екран Я просто хочу
нагадати про те що це 6 плану заходів
ініціативи партнерства відкритий уряд
цей план він орієнтований на максимально
повне і ефективне не використання бюдже
тних коштів на максимальну прозорість
максимально цифровізацію усіх даних які
мають доступні
суспільство в яких немає певних обмежень
з причин секретності і тому те що ми
почали в карантині і те що ми маємо
зараз дуже гарні проекти з реєстрації
онлайн
робіт і представлення їх Конрад В цьому
плані ці ініціативи розвиваються і
доповнюються І звісно те що козак
Олексій абсолютно вірно
реєстраційні картки Я дуже багато цінною
корисної інформації а в цих документах
але кожну картку потрібно відкривати
вручну якщо ти знаєш номер
державної реєстрації чи обліковий
державний номер і аналітична система
поки не побудована вона була у плані
вона обговорювалась а так щоб можна було
знайти
цілий клас наукових досліджень
відсортувати проаналізувати і вибрати
найкращий колективи або найкращі роботи
і напрямки для того щоб їх надалі
фінансувати
там отримувати гранти або ну працювати з
цими колективами на це власне і
розрахований даний пункт тому тут нема
протиріччя тут є лише на мою думку лише
прогрес який дозволить не лише окремим
людям А є інституціям грантодавцям
фондам РБК а також ефективно працювати з
цими даними
дякую
давайте будемо йти далі тобто я так
зрозумів що пункти 1.1 виконаний
тобто чого Чому він в плані що його
треба виконати я трошки не розумію
пане Олександре Що ви хотіли ще додали
додати що можна це буде мабуть в
коментарях до всіх пунктів такий
загальний трошки філософський але просто
я не думаю що з цього варто почати Я б
дуже хотів щоб Сьогодні ми говоримо
різні аспекти зокрема технічні і це дуже
важливо але як на мене
наскрізним абсолютно таким пунктом так
має бути
таке хороше намагання системним і робота
з дослідницькою культурою в Україні так
тобто коли ми говоримо про відкриту
науку про якісь технології які ми
впроваджуємо
повинні
досягти того рівня коли всім учасникам
процесу зрозуміло Навіщо це потрібно от
якщо всі будуть розуміти для чого так
для чого досягти наприклад бути
відкритому доступі тоді нам буде
набагато простіше дякую
Добре дякую
до другого пункту цього завдання
розробити та ввести у промислову
експлуатацію пошукову аналітичну систему
на базі реєстру розпочатих виконуваних
завершених відкритих Дір а також
захищених дисертацій з можливістю
фільтрування по всіх полях відомостей
будь ласка ваші коментарі я так розумію
Олена Сергіївна від вас йшла це
пропозиція
Ну ми взагалі вже мабуть там з 6
операцію проходимо це обговорень від
найпростіших ідей там які складалися з
цього з 4 пунктів
відкритість доступність
відшукуваність та ефективність і ми
дійшли до такої розгалуженої системи
заходів тут весь Захід Як коментувала
навіть не пункт 1.1 а весь захід весь
пункт 1 і йшлося про те що було
отримувати доступ не до окремих карток
або до окремих даних окремих дисертацій
або звітів а йшлося про те що
аналітичної пошукова система має
задовольняти
хоча б мінімальні потреби тих хто шукає
колективи які можуть здійснювати наукові
дослідження тих хто шукає кому треба
розпо
ресурси які так обмежені для того щоб
отримати найкращий результат для того
щоб не дублювати дослідження з боку
різних РБК тощо багато того пошуку який
наразі є він чудово працює в
індивідуальному форматі один номер одна
робота і набір інформації до неї тут
було йшлося про розгортання в систему
яка дозволить наприклад за ключовими
словами За напрямками
обрати цілий спектр усіх досліджень
дослідників і не вручну а комплексно
проаналізувати що такі-то колективи
працюють регулярно мають гарні
результати і ці результати такі а інші
колективи а від випадку до випадку або
лише разове підключались до цих
досліджень і потім цим не займались і
для того щоб вручну не шукати по кожній
роботі по кожному автору і по кожному
напрямку от про це йшлося тут всі
можливості і вся інформація є
наскільки навіть Я знаю з попередніх
консультацій йшлося про те що ці або
близькі до цих позицій вже закладені в
новий порядок державної реєстрації і
його виконання і тому мені здається що
це
це можливо зробити це буде дуже гарно
упаковці дякую Я пам'ятаю Нашу З вами
дискусію в якій Ви показували що слід
було б доробити всередині національного
репозитарію академічних текстів з точки
зору зв'язку матеріалів між собою в
різних Скажімо так частинах репозитарів
для того щоб окремий пошукач не
запускати для пошуку тих речей які тут
прописані тобто немає прямого зв'язку
між того що міститься в репозитарії з
пошуковою системою треба запускати
окремий пошук після того як ви щось в
цьому пошуку знайшли
Я так розумію що от про такі речі
можливо слід було б запитати наших
науковців Я не знаю
Олександре
Почекайте п Володимира давайте Ми
закінчимо думку можливо
пані Оксана можливо пані Анна може щось
сказати з точки зору ну знаєте як
практичної частини цього питання чи
можливо ви використовували
що в ньому треба було б щось допрацювати
з того про що говорила пана пані Олена В
цьому пункті 1:2 чи ні
як Доброго дня колеги Вибачте я Трошки
запізнилася так
Те що Точно Важливо щоб була єдина
пошукова система
шокованалітична по
цих різних ресурсах це однозначно що це
ну дуже важливо але я зараз ну просто не
хочу коментувати взагалі
систему в якій зараз це працює Ну тому
що маємо те що маємо ми при початку в
мене була абсолютно інша думка що варто
використовувати але рішення приймається
на основі багатьох
там складників і різні аргументи тому те
що це потрібно така
пошукова аналітична система і Ну що це
зручно і важливо це тут тому я думаю
ніхто не буде заперечувати а просто я не
знаю наскільки знову ж таки це
розробляти щось своє чи використовувати
те що існує тому що це знову те саме
питання
Я маю думку що треба використовувати те
що існує Діскавері систем навіть з Open
Source існують і ми в себе в
бібліотеці в КПІ використовуємо таке
програмне забезпечення
ми правда єдині в Україні поки що
використовуємо поза тим воно доступне
локалізоване українською мовою на різні
бази даних які
локальної
сорт використовувати тому тут
Що далі в ньому допрацьовувати це ж може
бути
безмежно оскільки це опенсурс ну це так
загальна така думка про те що пане
Олександре що хотіла додати
Дякую я чесно вам скажу навіть не дуже
активно користувач цією системою але я
просто невеличкий коментар
Ну я просто нещодавно ми там
обговорювали і вже більше такої системи
в яку вкладено драматично набагато
порядків більше грошей яка називається
і якщо хтось з вас спробував ним
користуватись знає наскільки це може
бути
таким досвідом
такий кажу так challeng який я виклику
нести
досвід а тому звичайно До чого Я веду те
що є місце для покращення це чудово так
і якщо би ну тобто подібні системи часто
мають на меті небезпечити точку входу
так звану для вченого який от почне свою
роботу Так з певної точки якщо би в
перспективі там двох років можна було би
виконати такий формат це було би чудово
але просто ну я хочу просто показати
наскільки це непроста задача Тому треба
працювати залучатись такий Колдер до
дискусій
Дякую пане Володимиру хотіли додати так
Хочу додати тому що трошки незрозуміло
щоб зрозуміли що ми зараз обговорюємо по
суті пошук по матеріалам які є в Нат він
організовує на є ви його бачення ну
скажемо там є є побажання щоб шукати не
тільки по тематиці наукових досліджень
да або по ключовим словам А ще шукати
скажемо по організації наскільки це
потрібно окремому вченому Ну я не знаю
Мабуть для того щоб зробити досьє на
організацію може і потий або чим
займається організація Хоча з точки зору
як дослідникам він може задати пошук по
своїй тематиці і отримати всі результати
А те що казала
Олена Сергіївна це стосується
обід робіт які розпачалися але не
закінчились
Ну ще не як тільки вони закінчуються в
цьому випадку організація здає звіт і це
попадає в національне депозитарій в нас
називається національна експозитаги
академічних текстів поки нема закінченої
роботи і звіта то пошук побачення
ніякого академічного тексту і немає
потрібен такий пошук потима роботам які
розпочалися то це пошук побачення і на
завдання депозитарій це завдання
іншої системи
ми ми
дисоціації
науково-дослідних робіт
вона не відкрита в плані на цьому цей ця
база даних для користувачів вона
відкрита тільки для тих хто є струм в
особистому кабінеті а над є відкритим то
це тоді надо писати що зовсім іншу
систему яка буде давати доступ до тих
робіт які розпочалися але не закінчені
на мій погляд з точки зору академічних
це текстів це нонсенс тому що вони
з'являються після того як робота
закінчена дякую
Ані Олена давайте пані Олена потім бачу
Олександра потім вже я
можливо
питання наша зараз така дискусія а хтось
про технології а хтось про
принципову необхідність цих речей і ми
трошки розгубилися або йдеться не про те
що академічні тексти недоступні а
йдеться про те що повної інформації яку
збирає яка збирається під час державної
реєстрації не може отримати ніхто в
форматі широкого структурованого
цільового пошуку ми можемо знайти в
ряд академічний текст або набір
академічних текстів або список
дисертації та ендокаїр і відкривати щодо
кожного картку яка дуже обмежена в дав
місто
і отримувати лише метода дані до цих
текстів А наприклад якщо якийсь
головний розпорядник бюджетних коштів
хоче замовити якусь тематику і він має
обмежені кошти і він хоче дізнатись які
були Дослідження які були витрачені
кошти і наскільки ефективними
результативними були ті чи інші
напрацювання у тих чи інших
усталених колективів то йому потрібно
кожного разу відкривати кожен
академічний текст потім відкривати
здійснювати пошук потім відкривати
шукати картку картки всього там 6 чи 7
позицій про фінанси там ні слова про
результати там ні слова і тощо тоді він
переходить в іншу систему віншій системі
вже за номером державної реєстрації він
знаходить Цю картку переглядала окремо
одну картку потім повертається один раз
знову шукає текст цієї темати він хоче
фінансувати знову переходить до
системи державної реєстрації таким чином
він кожного разу здійснює дуже багато
кроків по вже про тих роботах які
виконані немає чи доступу до можливості
там 5 чи там 10 кліків відразу отримати
якийсь ландшафт чи якусь картину
стосовно дослідження в рамках тих
дуже цікавих детальних і корисних
відомостей які збираються під час
реєстрації і Тут йшлося про інтеграцію
таких можливостей системи реєстрації і
інформація яка збирається і репозитарію
де якщо вже хтось зацікавився
матеріалами то він може відкрити їх і
почитати Але спершу він може не
чутуватись кожного окремо роботу
побачити ландшафт і цей ландшафт можна
взяти лише з даної державної реєстрації
я я так розумію що всі ці технічні
моменти можуть бути всі нашим колективом
то який зараз бере участь в панельній
дискусії а також іншими фахівцями
сформульований у вигляді деякого
технічного завдання для того щоб чітко
було зрозуміло що ви бачите недосконалим
в цій системі пошуку І щоб повинна було
бути удосконалена Ну а тепер давайте
далі слово Олександру і Андрію я дуже
короткий коментар просто в плані того що
публікувати
і їхні результати це зовсім не носом
Навпаки це одна з
принципі відкритої науки та пишуть
інформування
процесів створення і предприяти напевно
легко згадати тобто цей якраз навпаки Це
добре було би так робити тому Ну якщо
десь по такій якісь проміжні звіти
наприклад Чи наприклад набори даних які
поки що ще не стали статтею Так але це
вже прекрасний результат наукових
депозицій цілком навіть слушно тому
дякую дякую
Андрію я якраз хотів сказати те що
сказав пан Олександр що я дещо Не згодом
з визначенням академічного тексту яке
давав пан Володимир що навіть не
закінчене академічний текст Академічна
робота це все одно академічний текст і
його публікація це є позитивна тенденція
Разом з тим Я хотів би сказати що в мене
теж накладки Я теж Мушу бігти Я зараз в
чат скину пропозиції мої та панна
Серебрякова якого сьогодні з нами де
немає В нього теж накладка щоб
обговорили До пункту 5.1 я кидаю Цю
пропозицію в чат зараз для всіх щоб воно
була загальнодоступна коли дійдете до
того моменту обговорите А так всім Дуже
дякую і відкланяюсь добре дякую Андрію
Паніна
ну хотілося дійсно сказати щодо
практичного використання от відкритих
текстів Саме те щоб такі поточні
інформація була доступна це також у нас
обговорювалося на засіданнях ради
молодих вчених офісу підтримки вченого
тому що зараз як ніколи актуально
здійснюється підтримка українських
науковців часи воєнного стану і ми
зіштовхнулися Побачивши що от не вміють
наші молоді вчені вчені
знаходити отаку колаборацію науковців
із-за того що не знають де знайти і як
знайти цю співпрацю тому саме
ведення такого відкритої відкритої науки
відкритої демонстрації наукових
напрацювань поточних звітів і призведе
до того що ми можемо
налагоджувати більш якісно міжнародний
таку наукову співпрацю дякую
колеги я поступово пропоную перейти від
кроку номер один ми вже поступово якраз
ізотронули цю тему до кроку два що
стосується запровадження відкритого
рецензування наукових досліджень які не
містять інформації з обмеженим доступом
звичайно та виконувалося залученням
коштів державного та місцевих бюджетів
пане Олександре ми з вами багато
дискусували з приводу питань відкритого
ліцензування У вас є вже в деякі
виконані проекти з цього приводу тому
Мабуть я вам в першому надам слово дякую
багато що хочеться сказати
доведеться трошки якось лаконічно
насамперед треба зрозуміти що
відкрити рецензування це не є щось
визначене його Я дуже багато різних
варіацій
за нашим за Тоні роз хелуром партнер і
тому подібне це вчений який краще
досліджують там є Тобто ми говоримо про
відкритість
ідентифікатор людей осіб науковців і
самих відкриті самих рецензій так і теж
дуже важливе питання Яким чином І коли І
чи взагалі публікувати тобто я наприклад
підходив до відкритого ліцензування коли
публікуються ці всі дані у відкритому
доступі і репорті тільки тоді коли
прийнято наприклад матеріали до
публікації а в іншому випадку не
публікуються Я наприклад супер відкритий
підхід який зараз
практикують на платформісячних
Європейської комісії це інноваційна
публікаційна знаєте її третього доступу
Там повністю все відкрито так вони взяли
модель
запропоновано видавничим щоб нижчу
платформу тисячу фронтаун яка успішно
використовується зараз дуже багатьох
наприклад Меріда біос
мерлінда і кейджмент
ірландський дослідницький центр Там дуже
багато різних платформ і одна з цих
якраз опинилися вчора тобто тебе
зрозуміти що з цим треба
експериментувати але що я хочу сказати
що важливо як на мене
відкрийтесь яцензування це успішно
лакмусовий папірець готовності наукової
спільноти до принципів відкритості
посерйозному саме тому я почав сьогодні
першим коментарем те що люди повинні
зрозуміти для чого це потрібно не просто
сьогодні ми біжимо наприклад там
нарощувати індекс
а завтра ми біжимо повністю все
відкривати тому що це ні ну дуже важливо
донести зв'язок так
всіх ключових Стрільців
багато говорить на заході і на жаль не
дуже багато говорять у нас
яким чином це забезпечити зараз
наприклад нам потрібно експериментувати
нам потрібно зрозуміти який в форматі
відкритого рецензування буде для України
оптимальне ми зараз проекті оптіму яка з
намагається цих експерименту стану Ну
будемо ставити їх більше часу
останні
місяці Так останній рік був актуальність
реакцинування відкритого акцензування
тільки виросла в рази Чому тому що всі
ми знаємо про курор коаліцію з
оцінювання з реформування оцінювання
наукової діяльності так до якої Україна
теж починає потихеньку долучатися думаю
що складно з'явиться QR якщо подібні
речі там рацензування визнано як
ключовий ключовий практику для
переходу до якісного оцінювання так і
зараз і активний дискусії цього періоду
тому в Україні треба
[музика]
з цим працювати так зрозуміти яким чином
активність науковця в плані ліцензування
може бути нагородженою і оціненою так і
переходити як на мене до відкритості
тому що та платформа яка зараз не ставку
європейську комісія Opel
має Шанс стати стандартом і поставити
цей стандарт на Європейському континенті
Тому нам Треба рухатися в цьому напрямку
Дякую Олександре Хто хоче додати
декілька слів про відкрити рецензування
Я не зовсім зрозумів того що побачення
аж через що таке відкрити ліцензування
відкрийте В якому сенсі для кого тобто
будь-хто може ліцензувати чи ліцензії
у відкритий доступ чи знає
Того хто рецензує ну тобто наукова
робота яка ліцензується її автор знає
автоєценти Ну і так далі Тобто це мені
здається це не дуже прості питання
він насправді Я абсолютно прості питання
але не йдеться про те що я це зрозумів
хто жодним чином як правило запрошують
вчених ліцензувати рецензування як
правило за запрошення Так але
йдеться про те що
на відміну від так званого стандарту так
подвійного Сліпого рацензування про який
ми всі знаємо це
тестування передбачає те що ми знаємо
хто я рацензимку і ми можемо прочитати
його рецензії де це саме перше тобто
процес ацензування робиться відкритий
спосіб і окрім того в місці випадки
передбачено пряма комунікація разом
наприклад обговоренні ліцензії
дякую
Олександре Я пам'ятаю ви проводили ще
декілька років тому
експерименти з розбудовою таких платформ
можете Можливо там посилання показати як
це може бути теоретична реалізовано як
воно вже було реалізовано в Україні для
того щоб було розуміння
процесу декілька слів та я власне в нас
була є експериментальна платформа Львів
на конференції нам чимось що з цим
простіше працювати буде впевнений але
так От воно вже є і поводиться диски
політехніці і ми запровадили цей
перегнозування з ним справді є багато
проблем тому я і кажу що саме
відкритість до рецензування це є
відкритість до відкритого газування
є лакмусному папірцем готовності
спільноти до зміни академічної культури
і очевидно що це саме відбудеться
те що зміниться швидко але
ну що пояснювати людям Для чого потрібно
наприклад наука що вона несе такі її
переваги що потрібно для цього зробити
то ми можемо вийти на те що українська
Наукова система отримує дуже серйозний
імпульс і
потенціал до євроінтеграції насправді ну
є проблеми з відкритим рецензуванням
тому що в нашій культурі академічні
багато кому важко змусити себе публічно
хороші ціни але в цьому немає нічого
поганого Ну але це потребує роботи тобто
так це не просто і так це потрібно якщо
Дякую Ну ми поступово перейшли на пункт
2.2 які стосуються запровадження
обов'язкового грацензування остаточних
звітів виконання фундаментальних
прикладних наукових досліджень
науково-технічних експериментальних
розро що виконувались за кошти
державного бюджету та розміщення
рецензії у вільному доступі в середині
національного репозитарію академічних
текстів з відповідною перев'язкою до
повних текстів завершених відкритих Дір
та захищених дисертацій тобто якраз мова
йде про те що це було у відкритому
доступі І щоб люди
мали певне розуміння що це рецензія буде
відома всім Так пані Олена ви хотіли це
прокоментувати Я відчуваю
громадянський обов'язок прокоментувати
такі речі які нам обговорювались
віддискувались дуже жорстко і ми дійшли
до цих формулювань більш-менш таких
покійних Зважених і основним мабуть
мотивом
коли ми обговорювали було те що Дивіться
і порівнюйте два процеси наукових
досліджень про це з наукового
дослідження який завершується захистом
дисертації до філософії доктора наук і
процес наукового етану
зазвичай задіяно не багато людей
науковий керівник А там декілька разів
на рік чи нарада а власне здобувач
можливо місце де він впроваджував свої
результати І власне
опоненти і спектрада яка оцінює
результат все це прозоро і
Кошти які виділяються державою якщо
йдеться про навчання за державним
зрозумілі а вимог багато і вони жорсткі
тобто все це все це видно опоненти
відповідають за те що вони
пишуть в своїх відгуках А про те як з
чим вони виступають під час захисту
здобуваючи за це відповідає і все це
прозоро
разом із тим коли йдеться про
фінансування наукових досліджень то
кошти набагато більше врази На порядку
більші виділяються на наукове
дослідження і Далеко не всі головні
розпорядники бюджетних а коштів
проходять також жорстку процедуру
оцінювання результатів наукових
досліджень за які профінансовані за
кошти державного та місцевих бюджетів і
йшлося про те що хоча б в частині
оцього фінансування то що обмеженого яке
ми маємо від держави на розвиток науки
хоча б тут прирівняти отой процес
[музика]
великих вимог і до власного здобувача і
до його опонентів
до наукових досліджень і хоча б тут
зробити також рецензії щоб вони були
виконані відповідно до певних вимог без
порушення академічної етики щоб були в
публічному тоді людина яка рекомендує
вона не належить до авторського
колективу вона з зі сторони оцінює
результати і вона
підписується власними ім'ями Таким чином
не може вводити рахунки наприклад з тими
виконавцями які щось зробили гарне але
просто вони їй не подобається бо все
прозоро звіт відкритий рецензія відкрита
прізвище відомо обсяг фінансування
відкрити Таким чином такі прозорі воді
дуже складно шукати якісь непрозорі речі
от Це була кліткостенція наших дискусій
я хотіла щоб
Дякую Пані Олено
якщо Так пане Володимир
я хочу трошки додати
що це дуже непросте питання вот є
положення навіть закону про експертизу
який каже що опелюнювати
прізвища експертів передавати їх можна
тільки за згодою цих експертів
або друге я певне нестиковка в діях
Міністерства освіти і науки в якому
сенсі В тому що в Старому порядку
агітації навколо дослідних робіт був
пункт який
відповідає саме за експертизу тобто за
експертизу звідти Що там тебе було
поставити або саму експертизу або
посилання на документ з експертизою
звіту цієї органауково-дослідної роботи
на жаль цей пункт з нового порядку
виключено Тобто його спочатку ще треба
туди внести потім оформити в якому
вигляді Це дається експертиза і щоб не
порушувати права експертів
Дякую Так над цим я думаю попрацюємо з
точки зору нормативної бази для того щоб
у нас не було неузгодженості зрозуміло
якщо потреба ще брати виникне потреба
брати дозвіл на публікацію прізвища
експерта То це треба щоб було витримано
і ще треба змінити те про що говорив
Олександр на початку якесь таке
відношення до
відкритості і в тому числі питаннях
рецензування
давайте поступово переходити на
наступний розділ На наступний крок він в
меншій ступені у нас реалізований
в Україні - це питання управління та
збереження
науковими даних наукових даних
те що відсутні наразі в нас
в
місті національного репозитарію
академічних текстів про це в свій час ми
навіть і не думали Я так розумію коли
формували національний репозитарій
академічних текстів наразі тренд
збереження повторного можливості
повторного використання наукових даних
тобто по суті застосування фр в принципі
є
однією з вимог взагалі Отримання коштів
в рамках виконання міжнародних проектів
в тому числі по програмам горизонт
Європа євро там та іншим європейським
програмам і ці ж вимоги є і до
українських учасників українських
виконавців цих програм і вони вимушені
наукові дані наразі зберігати на
зовнішніх репозитаріях
наукових даних які не знаходяться в
Україні і перед нами зараз поста питання
чи то ми будемо розбудовувати умовний
національний репозитарій наукових даних
в Україні або будемо створювати окремі
репозитарії наукових даних так само як
створювались поступово репозитарії
академічних текстів в окремих наукових
установах та закладах вищої освіти Чи
централізувати цей процес чи де це
нейтралізувати чи просто очікувати поки
ті організації які є лідером виконання
міжнародних проектів почнуться
створювати самостійно але ж наразі Поки
вони використовують просто ту є
інфраструктуру яка існує в
країнах-партнера Отже колеги хто що хоче
додати прокоментувати по цій темі будь
ласка
так
Я пропоную подивитися ну тобто повинна
бути якась систематизація тут ми просто
взагалі по всім цим пунктам ми туди
понаставляли пункти все що захотіла
захотіла А з якої системи немає от і
попередніх касається особливо цього
пункту
скажемо опелюднити щодо рекомендації
щодо мета опису дані это по всіх галузях
знань по біології медицині сільському
господарству техніці тощо філософії
соціології про те що стосується наукових
даних то тут взагалі немає ніякої
прив'язки ви розумієте обсяг цієї я це
прекрасно я це прекрасно розумію тому і
Європейським Союзом була поставлена
задача розбудову європейської хмари
відкритої науки створення купу купу
окремих проектів які досліджували яким
чином це розвивати які технології
збереження даних обміну яку сперми
серверну інфраструктуру ну і купа-купа
всього дивіться секундочку що мене
турбує мене турбує на сьогодні не
включеність активна українських вчених
українських організацій ці процеси тобто
на рівні є оску
ідуть ініціативи по розробці по
пропозиціям нових проектів в рамках
програми горизонт Європа які
розвивали і створювали такі
інфраструктури і технології а українські
організації цих проектах або взагалі не
приймають участь або це точкові
виключення справи і нам треба нашою
когортою активних
представників української науки включати
з ці процеси
долучатись до цих команд проектів і в
тому числі якщо це буде робити у
карантині це буде супер якщо це будуть
робити інші організації це також буде
супер і Можливо колись ви почнете між
собою всередині України конкурувати в
кого краще технології в коробок краще
сервери краще підходи і таке інше от я
про це
повністю вас підтримує про статут стоїть
жовтень 24-го року і для всіх загалузей
до цієї дати це зробити Ну просто
неможливо і все інше я свого часу ще в
академії
пропонував трошки інший підхід до цього
От і можу один дві хвилинки розповісти
зараз по суті по суті майже всі журнали
да журнали вони
працюють вже в електронному вигляді
і обмеження на кількість сторінок в
статті по суті вже немає тому що
не треба вкладатися в обліковий аркуш
і якщо ми зараз науково публікацію або
того що саме академічний текст
представимо в електронному вигляді але
того ж ті інакше яким чином тобто є
назва є анотація Да є
коротка стаття стаття там 10-12 сторінок
є більш більша розгорнута стаття Я
просто кажу про імені і є додатки до
цієї статті в електронному вигляді який
включають в себе якраз оці наукові дані
і тоді
така схема ці наукові дані можна
подивитися використовувати там є опис що
з ними робити і тощо тому що не
починається пошук наукової з наукових
даних він починається Все ж таки з якого
там Meta опису тобто анотації тощо і
таким чином
ми маємо вже новий від публікації
розумієте і весь цей механізм зараз з
газу вкладається в і в систему
національного
коли ми маємо Просто ми беремо Нам все
одно як є економічний тест розширений на
розширений ми його беремо і маємо повний
доступ з позитив так і локальними
бібліотеками вони також можуть розширити
цю систему публікації яка вже буде
включати і наукові дані і не треба буде
авангалом
тут же ж буде складність точки зору
обробки потім повторної обробки цих
даних тобто треба ж розуміти як потім Це
знайти це ще окрема задача буде Давайте
я трошки дам слово ще іншим
представникам пані Оксана перша підняла
руку я
Я хочу Ну кілька таких позицій з цього
приводу озвучити Ну перше - Це точно
незалежно від того яка в результаті буде
прийнято рішення чи буде створюватися
якийсь національний або національні
репозитарії бо це теж може бути варіант
наприклад там умовно кажучи загалузями
знань кілька може бути таких репозитарів
можливо провідні університети в різних
галузях і наукові установи якось між
собою домовляться Чи координовано
державою чи там просто між собою
домовляться і подадуть якісь проекти на
там на єврокомісію і ці національні
репозитарії можуть бути можуть
функціонувати на базі цих наприклад
університетів чи наукових установ інших
а але ну тобто незалежно від того як до
чого ми прийдемо от в
результаті якщо університети будуть
окремі університети будуть подавати ті
самі проекти просто для того щоб
створювати
інституційні репозитарії даних так само
як ми починали з інституційних
репозитарій просто публікації в
університетах хто
Міністерство На мою думку точно має
підтримувати всі такі проекти тому що у
нас тут поле не пахане і син нам
розбиратися і розбиратися
і ще один коментар з приводу того
наскільки
це добре чи добре чи треба чи не треба
так робити коли об'єднувати в одному
репозитарії і публікації і Дані А це теж
потребує
вивчення додаткового і Ну я не глибоко
дуже глибоко не вивчала прямо так щоб
глибоко глибоко але із того тої якоїсь
інформації яка Ну так чи інакше я там
сканую з цих питань а тут Якщо щодо соці
гуманітарних наук це може бути простіше
і є такі випадки що я озвучувала на
попередніх робочих групах що є коли
там європейські університети приймають
рішення об'єднати такі але це
університети які займають займаються
суто соці гуманітарними науками а то
мені здається що із тими даними які
природничі науки технічні науки не все
так просто і тут ну мені це так
дуже огульна думка як це кажуть А мені
здається що це не вийде Ну може я
помиляюся Але я думаю що тут не все так
просто
однозначно
пані Олена
дякую
кожного
багато обговорювали ці позиції і
підводні камені і бачимо вже які
складності є в цьому питанні абсолютно
багато говорили і є однодумцями з
Оксаною брой і з Олександром борисковим
з іншими
людьми які працювали над національним
планом відкритої науки ми вже це
проговорювали але хочу звернути увагу на
такі пункти по-перше йдеться про
пілотний проект і вже Оксана про це
сказала або коли Володимир
Вікторович абсолютно справедливо казав
що ми в такій короткий час не розробимо
усі вимоги всі стандарти усі правила і
норми для усіх галузень А це було так
дійсно так ми це розуміємо і за обсягом
збереження інформації і за тими
стандартами які треба адаптувати
перенести перекласти
закладу відома науковців тому пілотний
проект обмежена кількість
спектрагалузень і відповідно залучення
досвіду від усіх партнерів європейських
які особливо у минулому у цьому році а
згодні а там нехтуватись своїми якимись
іншими справами і допомагати Україні
якщо є якісь такі великі масштабні
проекти які рухають Україну до вимог
стандартів Європейського Союзу тому я
думаю що досвід і ОСК певна до фанери і
окремих інституцій в Україні за кордоном
ми можемо для пілотного проекту
просунутися що зробити і я розкажу ще
один одну таку річ яка вона не є
секретом але вона
не афішували
16-му 17-му інформацію коли розроблялась
ідеологія національного репозитарію його
структура вимоги загальне бачення то на
всіх народах На всіх схемах і весь час
йшлося саме про те що ми будемо збирати
академічні тексти ми будемо збирати дата
встань ми будемо збирати дуже багато
речей які
описують пояснюють пов'язують пов’язані
з академічними текстами які були
зроблені в рамках дослідження І власне
розуміння і доступ до яких
підтверджує і дає нам довіру до власне
академічних текстів але коли ми дійшли
до
мін'юстував давайте напишемо академічні
тексти які погодили всі соки і та інші
пов'язані з ними дані і відповідно
зникли оці уточнення і доповнення про
які але ця мова на нарадах умон Але воно
як то кажуть між строчок воно є та інші
пов'язані з ними даних і дані у всіх
нормативних документах стосовно не раз і
можливо все ж таки в рамках пілотного
проекту ми зможемо просунутись Я дуже на
це Сподіваюся Дякую Олександре
важливих на мене розуміти
я розділяти тебе що ми хочемо Та і що ми
можемо
Навіть якщо ми розуміємо що ми зараз
чогось не можемо і в нас він бракує
ресурси у вас бракує ще чогось треба
розуміти що Куди ми йдемо тому як що я
починав Сьогодні знову продовжую тебе
розуміти для чого це і я тут пишу кілька
Тез на які хотів би відповісти
трошки Я теж спілкуюся з нашими колегами
західними і Розуміє як трансформується
їхнє бачення в плані наукових даних
наукові дані вже стали самостійним
абсолютно науковим результатом
і жодним чином не передатком до
академічних текстів уперше у другий
тут була теза що не починають
розгляд опису з наукових даних починають
більше того
Зараз обсяги інформації обсяги даних
наскільки великі
вони вже не піддаються дуже часто
обробці людини тому власне
[музика]
власне
багато хто з західних вчених вважає дані
первинними взагалі тобто важливіші дані
між наукові статті ця думка може бути
досить
революційною для нас але ну Багато хто
так вважає так це все культура дата
створення яка пов'язана з тим щоби
надати дані в обробку машинним агентами
програми агентам які зроблять роботу за
людей ти від світу ми мусимо це робити
стосовно розділення репозитарію даних і
репозитарії в академічних текстів Мабуть
це хороша ідея тому що
одне діло В мене є там відкриті дані які
опублікував опитування на один мегабайт
вам немає давайте подивимося
створено наприклад астрономії або в
сторону там генних наук Де кожен бтп -
це
терабайт це таке щось це дурниця Як ми
знаємо по цифрам що зараз дослідницькі
дані деяких галузях науки їхній обсяг в
Європі подвоюється що півроку так а це
було два роки тому зараз подвоюються
кожні два місяці тут ми тут підхід як
придатку не підійде Це просто треба
розуміти Куди ми йдемо так А який в нас
є можливості тому Ну станом назад якщо
насправді дивимося в сторону Європи якщо
насправді хочемо його вентиляції я би
особисто дивився в сторону використання
тому що Україна зараз мені вам пояснює в
якому стані
наша економіка та і ми не потягнемо
проектів навіть близько схожих навіть
віддалену схожих на еос чи на наприклад
пише з модуль який відкритий з нас нам
потрібно адаптувати нашу
регламентну базу до Європи
Олександре
ми ще коли працювали над національним
планом з відкритої науки то питання
наукових даних воно ввійшло таку окрему
дискусію з міністерством економіки і з
міністерством фінансів України і
Міністерство фінансів України
наголошувала на тому що під час
воєнного стану в Україні можливо це
питання не слід було б активізувати і
трошки почекати але я так думаю
сподіваюсь що ми разом з активними
колегами Можливо в рамках окремих
проектів розпочнемо роботу над тим щоб у
нас в Україні в принципі могли з'явитись
стюарди даних
щоб ці стюарди даних мали той Скажімо
так перелік навичок які мають стюарди
даних в сусідніх європейських країнах
щоб ми в цьому сенсі не відставали
в часі а з інфраструктурою Ну я думаю що
поступово поступово будемо підтягуватись
можливо воналогах проектів які зараз є у
Європейському Союзу по східному партнер
з партнерству на кшталт ябконект
ябконект 2 тощо і можливо ми ще з
колегами по цим проектом поговоримо щоб
в майбутньому після Другої стадії я б
коннекту можливо третя стадія була б
якраз присвячена
створенню такої є інфраструктури і
розвитку в Україні це як ідеї А ну вас я
призиває в тому що в ви все ж таки
активніше включились в роботу над
проектами які могли б
спільно з європейськими вченими
виконуватись
пов'язані з розвитком такої
інфраструктури і з можливістю
появи в Україні стюардів даних Я
пропоную по третьому пункту закінчити по
третьому кроку і поступово перейти до 4
кроку це підвищення вимог до
впровадження
[музика]
і залученням коштів державного та
місцевого бюджетів
питання зробити широко доступної
інформації щодо їх використання цінності
та суспільного впливу перша завдання на
цьому кроці Це розробка рекомендацій для
виконавців наукових досліджень і
розробок щодо впровадження отриманих
результатів та належного підтвердження
їх використання цінності і суспільного
впливу
можливо слід підключити до нас
приєднався пан Михайло голубяв ви з нами
пане Михайло погано На жаль чуємо
зараз чутно мене чи ні Бо немає мене
зв'язок поганий з телефоном На жаль
поганий зв'язок і у вас такий йде мова з
розривами
спробуйте можливо перепідключитись і в
такому тестовому режимі включити відео
для того щоб ми побачили з нами є Потім
я вам ще раз на там слово добре
колеги поки Михайло спробує побороти
технічні проблеми Хто хоче
прокоментувати цей пункт будь ласка
тільки одне запитання да А гроші де на
впровадження їх нема і не буде
І що ми з цим будемо робити тобто не
знаю
заохотити робити ці з одного боку з
іншого боку
я вам два десятка
роботі надрукують
з підписами Ну це вже питання про мабуть
академічну доброчесність доброчесність
тих людей які будуть друкувати такі акти
звичайно але ми сподівались щоб таких
такі випадки не відбувалися в Україні в
майбутньому пане Олександре
Дякую тут цей пункт абсолютно попадає
власне в
формування оцінювання наукової
діяльності так і тут якщо ми говоримо
про
впровадження
оцінювання цього впровадження знову ж
таки рецензування тобто про якісну
оцінку і справді пан Володимир кривий
тому що
зараховуючи нашу сучасну культуру
Я там якщо дуже захочу то теж отримали
за кілька тижнів це випадково за різними
паперами
І тут якраз Мені здається що оцей от
елемент відкритості і елемент того що це
можна все верифікувати так він може
допомогти тому що і те що в Україні
починає формуватися інститут репутації
Ми не говоримо про науковому загалом це
може посприяти І от така от повна
відповідність повна фіксація цього
всього вона може бути
[музика]
тим що змінить правила гри
Ну я позитивно бачите що я оптимістично
налаштований Я розумію що проблем і
запитань більше ніж відповідей але ми
мусимо кудись його Так звичайно тобто
і знову ми впираємося в те що
є ключовим це є культура Академіка Тобто
вона не з'явиться в Україні за одну ніч
і не за рік але що робити послідовні
кролики її напрямку це можливо тут
підкресли маємо розуміти Куди ми йдемо
як
дякую
Якщо пан Михайло не поборовся з
технічними проблемами то мабуть ми
будемо йти далі пане Михайло спробуйте
Добрий день Чи то мене так так
ні в мене нема поки що ніяких питань
тому йдемо далі
добре значить по пункту 4 є ще декілька
завдань які виписані в такий спосіб це
внесення змін до наказу мон в частині
додавання інформації провадження
результатів досліджень це виконання
комплексу науково-методичних та
організаційних заходів із забезпечення
додавання відповідних матеріалів під час
державної реєстрації а також під час
підготовки до захисту нас здобуття
наукового ступеня
а також виконання комплексу заходів із
технічного та програмного забезпечення
що додавання даних впровадження до
академічних текстів
ндкр і Дір та як та їх оприлюднення на
офіційному веб-порталі репозитарію поза
часовими рамками терміну виконання
НДР
такі пропозиції надійшли до нас від
громадськості вони були формалізовані і
запропоновані до впровадження
Якщо хтось хоче щось з цього
прокоментувати будь ласка
так
Мені здається що пан Олександрович все
правильно сказав бо ми дискутуємо з
питань які нам можливо внаслідок
багатьох зустрічей і обговорень
зрозумілі Ми не можемо все зрушити все
зробити ідеальним але зрушити з мертвою
точкою і рухатись А вона прямо в того
щоб особливо прикладні дослідження не
були
зроблені покладені там на полицю і
залишились там А це одна
один край проблеми інших країн проблеми
- це коли люди збирають дійсно
цілих стоси а документів які насправді
документами не є або Там просто написано
що такий-то колектив або така та людина
десь щось провадила або просто
впровадила свої результати невідомо в
денний як в умовах коли знову ж таки
ресурсів мало і ресурси мають бути
ефективно витрачені і цей бекграунд Він
має бути доступний то верифіковані
користувачі через там через систему
державної реєстрації або верифіковані
користувачі вже після того як робота
здана Чи захищена його опублікована Вони
можуть мабуть додавати відомості знову ж
таки прозоро підписом з
поясненням подавати ці відомості
додавати до результатів досліджень щоб
було видно що це не разове дослідження
яке закінчилось лише
науковою публікацією А що це дослідження
воно
впроваджено якимось чином на локальним
місцевому рівні в при розробці якоїсь
державної політики в яких підприємствах
і це буде знову ж таки звертаючись
інцитуючи Олександра Бориска це знову ж
таки буде інститут реабілітації і це рух
в рамках прозорості та ефективності
наукових досліджень взагалі дякую
колеги наступний пункт який трошки
виділяється Це розробка плану заходів з
популяризації науки з урахуванням
міжнародного досвіду зокрема принципів
Європейської Асоціації громадянської
науки єска цей пункт у нас
трансльорований
по суті без змін з національного плану
щодо відкритої науки і питання
популяризації науки зрозуміло що воно є
для майбутнього науки досить важливим
Ми нещодавно коли з паном Олександром
заповнювали
опитувальник європейської хмари
відкритої науки на Стівен Бордо
цій організації ТО
намагались знайти інформацію про те яким
чином підтримується популяризація науки
як вона фінансується і так далі і
згадувала ту ж саму малу академію наук
тощо тобто в нас насправді в Україні не
все так погано з цим і на фоні Я маю на
увазі інших країн в тому числі і країн
Європейського Союзу зрозуміло що ми не
можемо мати
такий рівень фінансування який має там
умовно Німеччина для цього Або там
умовна Франція Але у нас є і своя
інфраструктура і свої організації тощо
тому ми б хотіли б мати такий документ
десь наприкінці 24-го року Чому так Тому
що Ну ми розуміємо що для того щоб цей
документ був
реалізований після його прийняття
необхідно мати відповідне фінансове
забезпечення тому ми відсунули трошки
дату
перед для того щоб ну Ми віримо в те що
до кінця 24-го року воєнний стан в
Україні буде завершений Україна поверне
своїй території і можна буде трошки
вільніше звертатись до Мінфіну в точки
зору Отримання коштів на реалізацію тих
чи інших речей які будуть прописані в
цьому плані ну це окрім тих коштів які
можуть бути надійти тут з європейських
джерел або джерел інших організацій
значить і до п'ятого пункту переходжу
останнього по цьому пункту зробити
доступно на єдиному електронному
майданчику всю інформацію пов'язану з
процесом підготовки і проведення захисту
кваліфікаційних робіт здобувачів
наукового ступеня з метою забезпечення
прозорості процесу доступу усіх
зацікавлених сторін можливості брати
участь у процедурі оцінювання отриманих
результатів пан Андрій на початку просив
прочитати їх спільне з паном
серебряковим зауваження
де Він просив після
слів пункту 5.1 мабуть його слід було
прочитати тоді провести аналіз виконання
положень наказу Мон
зареєстровано в мін'юсті це наказ номер
554 від 15.06.22 року
Про затвердження змін до регламенту
роботи національного репозитарію
академічних текстів у разі виявлення
фактів порушення вжити кроки щодо
термінованого виправлення ситуації таке
інше доповнити слово Вони пропонували
цей пункт забезпечити можливість
індексації академічних текстів унрат
зовнішніми пошуковими системами
пошуковими болотами в мережі Інтернет в
тому числі інтернет пошуковому системами
забезпечити зовнішнім антиплагіатними
програмами доступ до обробки електронних
версій академічних текстів мират в тому
числі для використання їх для проведення
антиплагіатних перевірок а також
автоматизувати процес передачі
матеріалів донрад від інституційних
учасників закладів вищої освіти та
наукових установ колеги Хто хоче з цього
приводу щось прокоментувати будь ласка
ви можете прокрутити в
демонстрації екрану от до кінця
[музика]
коли ви дивіться справа я прокоментую ці
формулювання були взяті не з потолка
вони взяті з пункту 2 Де вказується
рішення тобто вони тут процитовані слова
в слово і вони передбачають реалізацію
наказу 554 особливо це стосується
індексації
академічних текстів їх електронних
версій
А це плагіатками та інтернету
пошуковиками
Це доволі проста історія вкрай необхідна
наказ затвердження Минулого року наразі
не в цій частині не виконаний а й
наскільки пам'ятаю якщо нічого з тих пір
не змінилося в Україні
був запроваджений разом з своєю
пл-сервіс щодо доступу до цих
економічних тестів що доводить що
реалізувати їх для всієї країни для всіх
антиплодіальних програм центр
пошуковиків технічні Можливо тому не
бачимо проблем що це реалізувати
в тому в травні 2023 року або у червні
якщо управлінські рішення буде прийнято
після травня
дякую
[музика]
колеги пане Володимиру
Михайло повторив про те що там написано
Я хочу просто прокоментувати віддати
відповідь на це запитання от Звичайно що
цей з деякими змінами до наказу Я не
зовсім згодний перш за все те що
стосується
відсутності реєстрації Тому що це є
якась можливість для аналітичної обробки
даних тощо Але якщо це цього не буду
касатися на те що стосується по
індексації ботами тобто після того як ми
повністю відкрили
доступ мені не треба ніякого реєстрації
тобто пане Михайло Ви можете пройти де
завгодно взяти любий текст його почитати
подивитися пройти по всій мові хоч
кожний дисертацію відкрити Я так розумію
[музика]
ніщо не заважає бо там точно так же як і
виходити будь-де багато будь-що завгодно
будь-що індексувати Так це нові погляд
виконана і є можливість інше
Я переходжу також до другого питання
тому що вони пов'язані інше - Це обсяг
даних зараз обсяг даних позначають
8-10 ТБ
у нас швидкість інтернету у нас за
кордон складає 20 МБ ви Візьміть 10 ТБ
поділіть На цю швидкість Ви отримаєте
кількість секунд які потрібно для того
щоб
будь-який бот або антиплагіатною
програма
це зробив скажемо є антиполегентна
програма для того щоб їй зробити і
взяти там сторінку тексту і порівняти з
усім що є в іпозитаги треба пройти по
всій апозитарію це 10 ТБ на швидкості 20
МБ Візьміть тому ми запропонували всім
з нами зв'язувався зробити взяти
комп'ютер да свій чи наш комп'ютер
поставити Його все гедину репозитає де в
нас швидкість 10 гігабіт
і будь ласка нам назовні Ви давайте
тільки результат
значить твоя це зробив Хмельницький ЗАЗ
вже закінчує робить вот залишився тільки
юнічек все будь ласка
виберіть ставте комп'ютер а він буде
працювати все
дякую
Ані Оксана
[музика]
і проблеми в мене таке Тоді уточнююче
питання і тут
зрозуміло швидкість інтернету її треба
збільшувати для того щоб воно нормально
працювало і я сподіваюсь що
бюджетнті Який я не знаю хто вам його
затверджує ви це подавали бо ви маєте
розуміння як нормальним шляхом вирішити
це питання але в мене трошки ну якби в
іншому питанні ви зараз назвали які
перше яким чином ви сповістили ось цих
гравців яких ви назвали які в Україні а
є ще інші Я впевнена що є якихось там
університетах розроблені власні там
засоби перевірки на текстові збіги яким
чином ви сповістили цих всіх спільноту
що всі можуть звернутися ось ці системи
і зробити це одне питання Ну я я одразу
і друге Ну на мою думку якщо це як
тимчасове рішення Наскільки я розумію це
має бути якось оприлюднено на всіх ваших
веб-ресурсах Ну у крентеінрата окремо в
тому числі і ще напевно через мон
розіслати якісь інформаційний лист на Ну
на все куди можливо куди мон розсилає А
ну я би так зробила я просто Це я зараз
моделюю а друге питання а ми ж говоримо
про те що не лише ті Системи які в
Україні ну мають потребу в принципі
це на на текстовій збіги Тому це теж
питання яке воно не вирішене таким чином
в будь-якому випадку дякую прошу
побачення я в 17-му році
коли я прийшов в Україну була спеціальна
нагада ми запрошували всіх хто має
відношення до блокади і Михайло в себе
якого також все інше Крім того ми робили
дослідження свої хто хто займається чи
чим займається тим бо було тільки дві
умови для тих хто займається плагіат
перша умова це те що вони працювали з
українською мовою Ну це зрозуміло Я так
думаю да Вот і друге - це те щоб вони
не мала Не мала російського походження
це на даний момент таких організацій які
дійсно працюють три я їх вам всіх
переохорон Це дійсно так от коди
по-друге Ми знов-таки більше року тому
до міністерством
послали і проект листа і проект щоб був
розіслати і проект
вимог технічних тощо але на жаль без
вершинку тоді чомусь це
застопорила не знаю чому от крім того ця
інформація у нас Олена Сергіївна є на
нашому репозитарі Мені здається була ні
не було б не було рішення стосовно цього
іменно згодили остаточне рішення і
відповідно цієї інформації
тобто
поставити якщо на сайті мон з великим
задоволенням якщо розіслати від імені у
кнте по всіх організаціях наукових які є
тільки в Україні
давайте команду Міністерства Я завтра
розішлю
я бачу проблему я в час скинув ссилку
доступ до бази даних у карантині я все
защита тобто не буду тільки заціпили дві
музеї нарешті сталося у карантині та
одна компанія підписала договір який
дозволяє перевірити робіт або як на базу
даних по карантині по карантині надає
доступ за спрощеною схемою що дозволяє
перевірити неомерну кількість робіт у
своїй вазі ну це те саме індексація ціна
за доступ до бази даних у карантині є 15
до 60 тисяч гривень Круто І наскільки я
пам'ятаю ці історії вже кілька місяців
ви говорили що пов'язку ел така
можливість зараз є Хмельницька
встановила до цього наближається і все
тобто у нас виходить що станом на зараз
є монополіст хоча
логіка 554-го наказу Вона зовсім інша
вона перед ну наказ передбачає надання і
всім антиплодіантним програмам без
обмежень
і навіть без обов'язкових там договорів
чи будь-яких бюрократичних історій і всі
в інтернет тут пошуковикам можливості
індексація цих текстів зараз таке
привели його не виходить доступ має одна
компанія це напряму порушує логікою і
буквою дух епізод 34 наказу і так і само
собою не повинно бути вони перевіряли і
Можливо щось змінилося Але от станом на
от останній нашу перевірку на все на
порталі репозитарію на сайті на сайті
немає немає
ні те що оголошення немає алгоритму яким
чином Якщо у вас є такі проблеми
інтернет-пошуковик або скажімо
програма зможе забезпечити індексацію з
собою у своїм програмними можливостями
текстів національного роботодарі так і
чомусь чомусь однієї компанії вона якось
організувалась і вона так недоступ є
Тобто вона інформована вона знає що вона
була робить щоб підписати це договір і
такий доступ забезпечити своїм клієнтам
А всі інші Ні ну це не конкурентна
історія і навіть якщо умовний юрічек
під'єднається Це знімає проблеми доступу
до текстів інтернет пошуковиків умовного
умовного гугу Як так просто виходить що
технічно забезпечує таку можливість
окремі компанії це Окей виходить а для
всіх інших ні
якщо відкрити доступ до несекретної
частини текстів Всім то само собою там
перші не знаю там тижні буде ажіотаж і
ажіотажний подих але потім ну це
складується так відбувається Завжди коли
щось відкривається світло
воно відкрите вже більше ніж півроку
Прошу пробачення і всі мають доступ і
вже ця проблема Інтернет пошук пошук
я інтернетно-шуковик серед якого я хочу
я ще раз кажу у нас канал 20 мегабіт
обсяг даних 8 ТБ у вас калькулятор є
Візьміть порахуйте будь ласка що
стосується підвищення
каналу все інше - Це навіть для аутии
досить великих грошей в принципі А нам
поки що Міністерство навіть на
комунальну на комуналки грошей тільки
Назад Ну це вже питання Не ці не цієї
дискусії і те що стосується інших пошук
пошукових в інших антиплагіатних систем
значить
знов-таки повторюю Мені кажеться ми
[музика]
зв'язалися з усіма компаніями на першому
етапі вони всі були
Але були тільки дві умови і я їх сказав
таких компаній виявилось в Україні
всього три
пане Володимире Ну давайте ми повторимо
просто цю історію для того щоб вона не
виглядала
давай і хочу пан у себе якого також
Сказати вашому сайті нашому сайті про
там вимоги до які кроки алгоритми для
того щоб можна було потрапити умовно
всередину
репозитанію для того щоб пришвидшити
пошук даних по ньому Я не знаю можливо я
б хотів би щоб п Олександре
прокоментував технічну питання от зі
сторони Олександре ви можете
прокоментувати з технічної точки зору
наскільки це
складна проблема
чи можна її швидко вирішити
я я так розумію команда Від міністерства
є Олени Сергіївна
працюємо на тему на репозитарій давайте
об'яви технічні вимоги і будь ласка
я не є людина яка приймає остаточні
рішення я пропоную це зробити
ви нам надсилаєте ви нам надсилаєте
пропозицію для того щоб можна було про
таке сповістити я відповідно до тих
процедур погодження засилає Цю
пропозицію на розгляд керівництва
Міністерства керівництва підтверджується
і ми опублікуємо це на сайті
Міністерства давайте
прийнятий Минулого року він вже
зобов'язався із зацікавлених осіб а саме
мон сам себе та розпорядок репозитарію
забезпечити індекс ось цю індексацію і
цілком Логічно що одним з кроків такого
забезпечення це інформація не конкретне
зацікавлених осіб А всі ну тобто в
загальному здобуті всіх так так що ти
маєш зробити щоб отримати такий доступ
погоджуюсь так
[музика]
добре колеги наша дискусія за часом вже
повинна підходити до кінця тому що ми
десь так години повинні були б закінчити
панельну дискусію давайте пан Володимир
декілька слів Ну і потім ще за бажанням
так
звертаюсь до межах Михайла себе Якого Да
вот це стосується плагіат зараз всі
системи плагіату всі які існують вони
побудовані на
співпадінні текстових фрагментів
синоніми не синоніми для того що і так
далі але
що ми будемо робити з появою Charge 5 От
коли ти береш будь-яку будь-який текст
даєш йому і кажеш виробити і все зараз я
знаю вже
студенти деякі да або може і багато хто
пишуть магістерські роботи
в тому розумінні плагіат який ви зараз
хочете запровадити він вже не має сенсу
розумієте
Ми живемо в епоху коли технічні зміни і
можливості вони просто йдуть по
експоненті і сам з чат GPS сам себе
тоді треба тут підходити зовсім з іншого
точки зору і коли Аллана Сергіївна
робила свою доповідь у нас не семінає по
планету ці схеми системи яким чином
перевіряються бо Вона розповідала в
цьому але мені зараз здається от що
в тому числі і
громадськість Да вот
вони перш за все думають не про те що як
зробити систему я би якраз зробити
екосистему академічних доброчесності А
как як існуючих там
начальників тощо
гектарів де гектарів
перевірити і їх потім шантажувати в
політичному або фінансовому сенс для
того щоб Прошу пробачення Ну нам перш за
все Коли ми починаємо боротьбу не
починаємо
боремося проти плагіат то треба подумати
якимсь чином
робити екосистему цього а не
конкретна хто написав дисертацію 92-му
році чи в 95-му вот шукати там
[музика]
дякую давайте ще декілька слів пане
Михайло пані Олена і будемо завершити
якщо можна пару слів кляті громадськості
позиція перша Володимира я щось не
пам'ятаю щоб за 5 років Я якогось
фінансував ту Чернігів шантажував
фінансово ми працюємо з усім Кабінетом
міністрів і якби таке сталося вже давно
попалося ми таким не займаємося
друга позиція по черзі gptm ми ну це
щось історія виникло явно пізніше
2017-18 року були приймалися в основну
нормативка репозитарів Наскільки я знаю
кадрові агентства в
історіях що стосується резюме вже
навчилися задавати чай GPT правильні
питання щоб потім ну знаходити резюме
які там були створені тобто людина не
слід без грантоплистує а
далі штучного інтелекту Ну і такі
стаискатель вони звісно не отримали
призначення тому що вони навіть
полінувалися нормальні резюме скласти
вони його вигадали ну такі Лентяево Ну
ось очевидно що дисертації це більш
складна матерія але якщо з'явилися
технології генерувати наукові дані То
наприклад з'явиться технологія
розпізнавання наукових даних
з часом позиція третє колеги на жаль на
жаль часу було дуже обман я в чат
надіслав ще одну пропозицію ми її раніше
подавали але отримали зауваження вона це
стосується того щоб тексти дисертації
оприлюдню ми тобі репозитарії не
післязавства а до захисту Ми отримали
зауваження Від міністерства з одного
того що історія У нас є порядок
ресурдження наукових ступенів дихторів
філософії доберіть наук там є алгоритм
де публікується в якійсь строки проєкт
ну умовно проект дисертації Перепрошую
ми пропонуємо ми зкорегували свою
пропозиції і брати партнера собі
відкритий уряд і реалізації політики
відкритих науки пропонуємо до ось цих
двох процедур присуджені і позбавлення
наукових ступенів несе доповнення згідно
з яким бажано за місяць два але строки
ми тут неполягаємо завчасно головне
оприлюднювати в національному репозитарі
десертації Та ну не таємні само собою та
супровідні матеріали чому це важливо
тому що зараз є вимога про публікації
цих матеріалів на сайтах закладах вищої
освіти наукових установ а вже існує сили
ринок не дуже доброчесних закладів які
максимально приховують своїх метрах ці
дисертації дуже глибоко
неможливо знайти і от будь-який цскатель
плагіата він його там не знайде навіть
якщо дуже постарається це треба знати
гарантовано треба точно знати що шукати
А 10 робочих можна щоб не затягувати
питання Михайло я прокоментую відповідно
до чинного законодавства саме постановка
кабінету міністрів про порядок
присудження дисертація в Україні
здається за 10 днів до захисту
тобто фактично набрати Вона може попасти
за 10 днів без захисту це все вже
передбачено постановами Кабміну А
стосовно пошуку
як ви кажете в меблях сайтів інформації
де розміщена дисертації відгуки
опонентів То єсть з 1 травня ми маємо
повідомлень про захист в якому в цьому
повідомленні буде безпосередньо
посилання на ту інформацію що стосується
заходу і особа яка хоче з цим
познайомитися заходе на сайт
Міністерства відкриває
повідомлення про захист і там будуть усі
посилання
прекрасно це означає що треба ці
повідомлення
моніторити календарно Тобто всі підряд
такі повідомлення відповідно до
постанови Кабміну розміщуються на сайті
Міністерства третього робочого дня
наступного місяця
в цих повідомленнях іде інформація
стосовно теми дисертації це
виставляється
умовно за два місяці до захисту і
безпосередньо буде посилання де
розміщується дисертація на сайті
установи чи зради Давайте так щоб ми не
пропонували то що можливо буде вирішеним
Давайте ми ну я дивлюся Всі ресурси уже
законодавче вирішене якщо якщо питання
дефекту вирішення ми не наполягаємо але
якщо воно не вирі ми хотіли це питання
оперативно дослідити тому що в нас
змущає до спроб 10 днів якщо він
де-факто більший прекрасно Королева в
чому якщо є фахівці які зацікавлені у
тому що ви перелапатите сотню сторінок
матеріалів тощо видно у них має бути
якийсь режим сприяння хоча б на рівні
знайти цей матеріал Давайте ми дійсно
Подивимося як здійснюється ось це
оприлюднення якщо умовно
пошуковику Gladiator можливо це зробити
я маю на увазі людині то Окей якщо ні то
ми скорегуємо формулювання Але у вас
просто було зауважене таке що на рівні
накази це врегулювати не можна Окей ви
просили внести зміни в наказ наказ зміни
Ми не можемо внести По тій причині що
він стосується і кандидатів наук як
відомо порядок присудження 567
скасовано але законом передбачено що
здобувачі наукового ступеня кандидати і
Доктора наук які розпочали свою
підготовку до прийняття закону України
Про вищу освіту користуються тим
законодавством яке було на момент
їхньої підготовки
тому в наші зміни цей наказ ми нічого не
зможемо зробити тому що вони будуть
казати що А ми в 2015 чи 14-му розпочали
підготовку і на нас поширюється дія на
саме того наказу і який був той період
тому ми її постанові кабміна спеціальної
Прописали що дисертація в Україні
потрапляє до за захисту
наказ не підходить старі історії на
підходять але нові історії тобто нові
дисертації
нові історії нові дисертації всі
здобувачі ступеня доктора філософії
інформаційна система назява є інформація
про публікації є всі посилання на
публікації є посилання на дисертацію є
посилання на онлайн-трансляцію все в
реєстрі за пошуком за вибором за
спеціальностями за галузями все що хочеш
Дякую вам дякую
колеги колеги дякую давайте пані Олена
буквально хвилинку і будемо завершувати
Дякую я підняла руку коли була дискусія
між Володимиром та Михайлом стосовно
перевірки і нових технологій і мені дуже
крутіло ввімкнути мікрофон відразу але я
отримала насправді питання надзвичайного
гострої актуальне ми це бачимо бо ми
почали відслідковувати публікувати усі
новітні зарубіжні вітчизняні
публікації заходи в дискусії стосовно
штучного інтелекту там великих мовних
моделей їх застосування і чаті додатків
на їх основі на ресурсах не грати ми
бачимо що публікації одразу отримують
у 3-4 рази більше прочитань і відгуків
ніж інші Тобто це дійсно дуже гаряча
така питання але ж є чат GPT з якими вже
за 18 лютого працюємо в Україні
деяких VPN обмежень стосовно розробників
і є час зірок який вже вміє визначати що
написано чатом GPT а також інші
антиплоїдні програми підтягують свої
технології до того рівня щоби
відрізняєте де пише штучний інтелект де
людина зрозуміла що це проблема складна
і технічно Але сподіваюсь вона буде
вирішена бо людство так і йде
знаходиться якесь новий інструмент а
потім знаходиться багато способів роботи
з інструментом і
детектування того що він використавний
Але ж ми не про штучний інтелект А про
весь комплекс заходів я хочу подякувати
усім учасникам усім колегам хтось
сьогодні долучився до нашого обговорення
дискусія була непроста
конструктивна і я думаю що кожен записав
багато пунктів на які ще треба звернути
увагу
повернутись до їх осмислення а
узагальнюючи той документ який ми
обговорювали Я хочу сказати що на мою
думку після оцих багатьох раундів
обговорень пропозиції які є в цілому
відповідають тим критеріям які були
визначені ініціативою партнерства
відкритий уряд і секретаріатом Кабміну
коли а критерії були зазначені
відкритість прозорість ефективність
цифровізація та інновацій і мені
здається всі п'ять пунктів а більшою чи
меншою мірою
віддзеркалюють Саме ці критерії Я
сподіваюсь що ми можемо просунути ці
речі у практику дякую
пані Олена Дякую всім хто сьогодні брав
участь в нашій панельній дискусії
сподіваюсь що
кабіне Міністрів України підтримує в
найближчий час
Ці пропозиції які були
запропоновані громадськістю спільно з
міністерством освіти і науки надані на
загальнення Секретаріату Кабінету
Міністрів України і ми разом з вами
протягом найближчих півтора років будемо
реалізовувати
напрацьовані ініціативи
Ще раз дякую всім і до наступних
зустрічей
Дякую до побачення
колеги я закінчив трансляцію
на YouTube канал
пан Володимир вже вийшов Ну і